when you make it personal it just you
know I don't know you want everybody's
gotta be they do want your opinion
everybody's got to be like I want to see
you
like if you're whether you're Chappell
or whoever if you're whether you're
talking about politics are you just
talking about going to the gas station
everybody's got to want to see you the
comedian go through that experience so
that's what you have to be able to
that's what you're kind of selling to
the audience because you got to be like
here's me going this you want the
audience to kind of be when they watch
it like I could see this guy doing this
this is what he does like that's that
means they're buying into what you're
what you they they know who you are and
that's when you get to like you get to
another level where then you're like
you've kind of got your that's like a
your voice you need to see comics paths
mm-hmm
so you find a comic that like you know
how is what say you got to have a comic
above you and below you you need to have
like someone that you talk to that's
right above you and then you need to
talk and you need to help someone that's
right below you in comedy because you
need to you know there's no point in
going if you're starting today you don't
need to go talk to Ray Romano about
stand-up you're you have nothing to
relate he hasn't done open mics in 30
years
like there's nothing he can really tell
you you know besides like the basic
information that you'd get is they just
work hard write jokes all that stuff but
you need to talk to some of it's like
two years in because that person would
know more than anybody that's that's
what you need to learn is what to do in
two years versus what to do in 20 years
and then you always think you have
someone below you so you can resave this
stuff to someone because you need to
constantly be hearing yourself say it so
you need to be saying it helping someone
else you know below you can kind of talk
and that way you're always just talking
about you have to be doing it every
night boom
you have to like I'm a big look if you
have a girlfriend a wife husband
whatever if they are in your way and you
try to like be like well I got to do
stuff with my girl like I can't like go
do all this stuff then you just won't
make it probably like because you're you
know I say this a bunch and a lot of
things but no one cares that you're
trying to be a committee
no one needs you to be a comedian no one
needs me to be a comedian no one needs
bill burr to be a comedian we're all
choosing a job that's like winning a
lottery ticket you're choosing a career
where you can make zero dollars or you
can make 950 million dollars like
Seinfeld like that's your window your
window it can be all over the visor you
make a million you can make know
whatever so if you don't obsess over it
then you will never do it because if
you're not obsessing over it someone
else is obsessing over me and they just
spot the fact that they will just be
around you just got to be around you've
got to be even if you're not doing
stand-up every night like you just have
to be where everybody knows you're a
stand-up
everybody knows you're doing stuff and
you got to be soaking everything in and
I remember like Bobby Kelly would always
like talk about like Bob Marley would
murder buddy like I love that's
something that newer comics need to have
you know then I think this is there
because there's a mix of comedy that I
think there's a lot of comics now that
like laughter is not the most important
thing to do and it's about like being
one or whatever it whatever it is right
so if you look at look I came up in the
New York Times and like where guys would
murder dude like Ben Bailey Greer Barnes
I mean murder like music I can't believe
they're watching this dressed up that
needs to happen yes if daddy come back
it's like there's a new way of people
writing I think comics writing jokes
where they're very safe they're like
it's like well like meander stuff is
very funny so if you don't laugh it's
like it's kind of fine none of its
that's funny it's all like oh yeah
that's a good point like all that kind
of stuff right and that's wheat in the
book he said he knew any time he started
feeling uncomfortable it was time to
make a change and so then he moved to LA
I mean I read Oh two months after our
read back well I moved to Los Angeles
from New York because I knew they made
so much sense and it's the best quote
I've ever heard is the fact that like if
you start building cars like the guy
that was living in Chicago yeah if your
lips got no and you're having no trouble
getting on any show in Chicago you can
get up as much as you want and you're
kind of low
that is like one of the older comics or
a higher-level comic then you have to
move and you need to shake it up if you
don't you will get stuck
are you or just get stuck there and
you're just gonna be the older guy and
new comics are gonna come and they're
gonna pass you and they're gonna move
and then you're gonna end up you can
start becoming bitter and you can start
and then it's gone
it's over if you're serious about
becoming a comedian join our Facebook
group linked in the description below to
start getting tips like these every
single day and watch this playlist of
our top writing tips to improve your
writing today